opioids are drugs that are prescribed to
treat moderately severe or severe pain
heroin an illegal drug is also an opioid
opioid addiction is a brain disease
where you have an overwhelming craving
for the drug
you can't stop taking the drug despite
the harm it may cause you
an important treatment for opioid
addiction is called medication assisted
treatment or matte
matte is a whole patient approach that
combines medication to help you stop
using opioids with counseling and
behavioral therapy
three common medications used to treat
opioid addiction are methadone
buprenorphine
and naltrexone
in the brain
each drug attaches to the same receptors
on cells as the addictive opioids
methadone activates the receptors
but it's a slower acting drug than other
opioids because it takes longer to reach
the brain when used as prescribed
this reduces the high feeling and
prevents withdrawal symptoms
buprenorphine is a weaker drug than
addictive opioids because it doesn't
activate the receptors as strongly
it also blocks other opioids from
attaching to the receptors
as a result it reduces cravings for
addictive opioids without making you
feel high
naltrexone blocks the opioid receptors
by attaching to them so addictive
opioids can't
this prevents other opioids that get you
high from working
it does reduce cravings but does not
stop withdrawal symptoms
drug treatment is more effective when
combined with behavioral therapy
therapy can help you handle stress and
life events that can trigger cravings
for opioids
opioid overdose is a condition where
taking too much of the drug may cause
life-threatening symptoms
call 911 immediately if you think an
overdose has happened
start cpr if the person isn't breathing
the main treatment for an overdose is
naloxone
it's an injectable drug or nasal spray
that quickly blocks the effects of
opioids
you can help prevent opioid addiction
and overdose by taking non-opioid
medications for pain when possible
taking opioids as prescribed by your
health care provider
and doing physical therapy or exercising
as recommended by your health care
provider to help manage your pain
for more information about treating
opioid addiction and overdose talk to
your health care provider
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you